من المؤسف أن يكون توقيت
وفاة الملكة هذا العام
عائلات تعرف أنها
ستكون دائمًا خلافات ولكن ربما
كان من الممكن أن يكونوا أكثر
مهذبًا من ناحية التوقيت مع
جدهم وأفراد أسرتهم ،
أعتقد أن هذا هو المكان المناسب.  لم يتم
أخذهم على محمل الجد كما كان من الممكن
أن يكونوا ، إنه أكثر قليلاً
لأغراض التلفزيون بدلاً من
معرفته لما قد
يفكرون فيه حقًا ، فالطريقة الوحيدة التي
يمكن من خلالها تنمية سمعتك أو تحسينها هي
إذا كنت تستخدم  الصفحات الأولى للصفحات الأولى
من تلك الصحف ، لكن وسائل
الإعلام هي التي تختار من ستضعه في
الصفحة
الأولى ، أعتقد فقط أنه
توقيت سيئ جدًا عندما يعرضون هذا
الفيلم الوثائقي وكأنه
أناني قليلاً لا يفكر في
التفكير ، أعتقد ذلك على ما أعتقد  إنها طريقة جيدة
لكسب الكثير من المال شخصيًا بعد
حدث كان فيه كل فرد من
أفراد العائلة من كبار أفراد
العائلة بما في ذلك الملكة وعلى
الصفحة الأولى من الشركة المصرية للاتصالات.  ليجراف ميغان
[موسيقى]
دراما متضمنة ولكني لا أعلم
أنني لا أريد أن انحاز إلى جانب واحد ولكن
أعتقد أنه لا ينبغي أن يكونوا قاسيين جدًا على
العائلة المالكة لأنهم جزء منها
خاصة هاري لا أعتقد ذلك شخصيًا.
إذا وافقوا على عمل هذا
الفيلم الوثائقي ، فإنهم على ما يرام
مع بطاقة الهوية وأعتقد أن الفيلم
الوثائقي مفيد للغاية وتعلم الكثير
عن حياتهم ولا أعتقد أنهم
جيدون إذا كانوا على ما يرام مع
ذلك  يجب على الجميع الاحترام وهذا كل شيء
حتى نتمكن من الانتقال إلى
الفصل التالي ، يجب عليك إنهاء
الفصل الأول ، فقد منحنا فرصة
لإنشاء ذلك المنزل الذي طالما
أردناه
[موسيقى]
لطالما شعرت به  كما لو كانت هذه
معركة تستحق القتال من أجلها